a man with a van is one of the engines
of the gig economy I make about 80 to 90
delivery today
but those behind the wheel like edy
often self-employed on zero hours
contracts can ill afford to stop work
the corona virus that would self isolate
just to do the right thing but no it
worries me more not being able to earn a
living because you know we can carry on
working and we may not catch the corona
virus it took it's a gamble but at the
end of the day we still have bills
coming in every month the government
wants those at risk to self isolate it
is currently refusing to extend sick
play to 7 million self-employed or low
paid workers with a five-week wait
before any benefits are paid many may
feel they have no choice but to ignore
health advice and keep working this is
the time for the government to act to
make sure that people do have access to
sick pay when they need it if they need
to self isolate or if they feel unwell
they they cannot face this impossible
choice of whether to go to work knowing
that they might be infected or losing
out on money that they need a serious
outbreak could have profound impacts on
the way we live and work with
predictions that up to 20 percent of
people could be absent by the sick or
self isolating for anyone in a
customer-facing job like retail working
from home simply is not an option and if
thousands of low paid staff have little
choice but to keep working even if
they're advised not to it could
undermine efforts to delay and contain
the virus even in these early stages the
economic impact is being felt retailers
were concerned around three main areas
they were concerned about the continuity
of supply they were also concerned about
the potential impact
on labor and staff shortages but the
most important factor was actually their
concerns around consumer confidence they
want consumers to remain confident
essentially about public transport
visiting public destinations whether
that's restaurants or eating out but
also around shopping destinations as
well it is an irony that in a prolonged
outbreak the sick and self isolating who
rely on services like food and goods
delivery provided by those who can least
afford to do the same
Paul Kelso Sky News